everyone I'm Dan from Fandango movie
clips and these are things to know
before you go to Terminator Genisys
first off Terminator Genisys is being
described as both a sequel and a reboot
and more or less ignores t3 and
Terminator Salvation and instead resets
the franchise's storyline through time
drought call it a seek bud or a recall
or a boot quill or at night bullet so
let's take a look at the two films the
genesis does refer to starting with 1984
is sleeper hit the Terminator this movie
introduces us to Sarah Connor whose son
John leads the future war against the
machines when the evil machines send
back a terminator to kill Sarah before
John was ever born future John sends
back rebel fighter Kyle Reese to protect
her together Sarah and Kyle take down
the Terminator in an epic finale that
reveals the Terminator exoskeleton
Terminator 2 mixes things up by casting
Arnold as the good guy when the
shape-shifting t1000 is sent back in
time to kill a ten-year-old John Connor
you reprogrammed Arnold arrives on the
scene to protect John and Sarah
not only does Arnold save John's life he
also helps the team take down Cyberdyne
systems stopping the nuclear fallout war
known as Judgment Day from ever
happening until they realize how much
money is moving then it happened
t2 was a critical and commercial hit not
only did it feature one of Arnold's
strongest performances it was also the
first film to star a partially CGI
character Emilia Clarke is our new Sarah
Connor Emilia is the third actors to
play Sarah Connor and will be teaming
back up with director Alan Taylor who
should work with on Game of Thrones Jai
Courtney is the new Kyle Reese Jai is
the latest Terminator actor to get
completely naked while time-traveling
and although this movie's pg-13 we may
still see some skin Jason Clark is the
sixth actor to play John Connor and
rounding out the cast is Eve Jung Hyung
who is the second actor to play the
lethal p1000 so for those of you keeping
score at home that is three Sarah Connor
is to t1000 three Calvary's the sixth
run Connors and one confuse got me but
there's plenty of new and exciting
things to this installment for example
John Connor will be playing a villain
for the first time after being
manipulated and taken over by the
Machine and Arnold will have his hands
full battling not just John but also his
own younger self yeah the freedom
fighters will once again be fighting to
stop Judgment Day but don't expect them
to get the job done in this installment
as Genesis is set to be the first in a
new trilogy of Terminator films
Terminator creator James Cameron has
already praised the movie
that he considers Genesis the true third
film in the series so be sure to check
it out in theaters soon i'm dan frolic
from Fandango movie clips thanks for
watching remember to subscribe find me
on Twitter and follow me if you want to
live
the term knit a reference come on I feel
like I deserve at least 15 followers
back
[Music]
you